c'est un trésor qui voyagent
discrètement dans une modeste pochette
en carton
il a patienté plus de 130 ans dans
l'anonymat quant au printemps dernier le
descendant d'un militaire orléanais a
contacté la société des amis de marcel
proust pour révéler l'existence de ce
texte que l'auteur avait offert à son
grand père à l'époque de son service
militaire
l'héritier est resté en possession de
son chef-d'oeuvre mais les projeter en
trouver par hasard un autre exemplaire
en salle des ventes
et quelques mois plus tard on a
découvert que ce même problème existait
dans une autre version antérieure de 2
ans que proust avait envoyé à l'un de
ses camarades de lycée raoul versini
donc il ya deux versions différentes qui
s'asseyait rigolo d'ailleurs parce qu'il
a utilisé le même problème pour le
dédier l'envoyer avec une dédicace
personnalisée à deux personnes
différentes en dosant d'état
c'est ce deuxième manuscrits facilement
authentifié grâce aux boucles
particulière de sa graphie que le musée
marcel proust a acquis grâce à des
subventions publiques
mais déjà une minute qu'on en parle et
vous aimeriez sans doute savoir de quoi
qu'il cause le texte en hausse vers du
grand homme dont voici les premiers
arrêtons la musique les souffles
flottant dans les bois en fleurs à
bordeaux feuillage est insolent luise
les glaïeuls ruisseau ampleur au ciel
bleu foncé nage un nuage blanc l'air
tiède et doux ou poitrine blanche mise à
nu c'est un poème un peu vers les néons
de la manière dont verlaine écrivait
certains poèmes un peu vague mais
érotique on dirait et
qui raconte en fait l'histoire d'une
promenade dans un bois entre deux hommes
visiblement deux hommes qui s'entendent
bien qu'ils vont profiter pour avoir une
relation un peu sentimental ou peut-être
des caresses sous des branches il ya des
choses un peu étonnante
c'est d'autant plus étonnant que qu'on
imagine que c'est un poème qu'on adresse
à un supérieur de son service militaire
on jugera ni la qualité de l'oeuvre d'un
lycéen ni les qualités morales de
l'homme qui offrent le même cadeau à
deux amis ce texte appartient maintenant
à l'histoire littéraire publié cet
automne dans les cahiers marcel proust
ils devraient être visibles dans les
prochaine exposition consacrée à
l'écrivain dont les admirateurs
célébreront le 150e anniversaire de la
naissance l'année prochaine
[Musique]